these are all reverberations and effects
of stripping people of opportunity and
jobs then we go back and say well we
have these food deserts and why are they
just eating these things well look at
yourself in the [ __ ] mirror you know
Roy Roy is known to many as the man who
started the food truck movement with
Kogi barbecue a delicious mashup of
Korean and Mexican food
what made Kogi a hit was choice ability
to blend different flavors a talent he
credits to his upbringing on the streets
of LA well I'm an immigrant here in this
country you know I'm American but you
know my parents came over here with not
much and we had the hustle and we moved
a lot we did a lot of different things
to survive it gave me an understanding
of how not to be racist whether you do
to the do haves or don't have you know
like it you taught me to figure out my
situation and be connected with with all
people Troy now has over half a dozen
restaurants and New York Times
best-selling memoir and is considered
one of the top chefs in the world he now
wants to take the ideals of street food
and use them to bring healthier food to
low-income neighborhoods he's partnered
with Michelin star chef Daniel Patterson
to create local a new restaurant in the
heart of South Central Los Angeles well
we're in watts we're right in the heart
of the Jordan downs projects the best
picture I could paint is a place filled
with history love smiling faces
beautiful beautiful beautiful people
the 1965 Watts Riots left the
neighborhood in ruins and over 50 years
later economic hardship continues to
define the area today 40% of residents
live below the poverty line and suffer
from high rates of obesity and other
health ailments Los Angeles's health
atlas showed that people who live in
watts have the lowest life expectancy
rates in the entire state joy hopes that
local can begin to reverse this trend by
serving residents healthier fast food
with a menu that includes old classics
like burgers and tacos and lighter
options including tofu bowls and fresh
juice what you see is fast food so that
way any anybody who walks through these
screen doors when they look at the
you I want them to have almost like an
instinctual reaction to it like oh look
at that look at that let me have that
that's the taco that's a fold eat that's
a bird and as they eat them when they're
done eating and they're walking away
like 15 minutes they're like I don't
feel like a horrible I feel good you
know I feel like jumping over that fence
right now you know like that that's what
I hold joy is motivation for opening
local is to combat food deserts which
are areas that lack access to fresh
produce and grocery stores but several
studies have questioned the existence of
these food deserts and they're linked to
poor nutrition researchers say that it's
not that people don't have access to
fresh fruits and veggies it's just that
they don't want to eat it do you see it
that way is it a question of access or
is it a question of cultural preference
and if so like how do you approach
trying to change that half of it Daniel
myself felt like food was the fastest
thing that we could affect and that we
in it was the it was the one area and
loophole that we could like slide into
because everyone has to eat but really
it's a typical iceberg of a larger
discussion Choi's argument is that it's
more of a mental hurdle whether
youngsters or adults to make their
decisions you know and lead themselves
in devices or addictions or whatever it
is out there that's not what I'm trying
to really talk about what I'm talking
about is it's the fundamental belief
that we all believe that we have these
choices these equal choices what local
is about is about looking our selves in
the mirror and saying listen it doesn't
have to always be a fight okay yes we
all messed up but listen that's the past
are we going to continue this for the
next 50 years or are we gonna start some
sort of change where everyone has an
opportunity and it's not just because of
your cultural background or the color of
your skin while policy makers have taken
a mandate approach to putting healthier
food in low-income areas choices he
doesn't have time for macro level forces
to make change he's looking to community
solutions to fix the problem before
local he worked with students at
Jefferson High School in South Central
Los Angeles to develop a menu of healthy
drinks and snacks teens would wanna buy
and then gave them jobs in the new cafe
how did that work out do the kids want
to eat those type of foods when they had
more control over yeah of course I mean
it's about your choices again it's about
what you offer
it's about your intent if you're lazy as
a leader or a parent or whatever on an
organization and if you just say like
your only choices in life are macaroni
and cheese and frozen burritos and
pepperoni pizza and those who only think
kids are gonna like or those only things
that I as a parent is gonna are gonna
provide then of course the people around
you are only going to want those things
but if you break that and say and just
start from the premise of cooking
delicious food or making delicious
smoothies and you just go from there
then whatever's in front of them they
will like you know because it's
delicious and so what we do here is we
lay a lot of groundwork and we ask
everyone like we listen you know what do
you weak what do you want to eat what do
you crave D what do you what haven't you
ever had that you want to eat you know
like that you wish you could eat and we
started talking about the menu we start
talking about the food start showing
pictures of who we are and our food and
and we start asking real real questions
I think the difference is a lot of times
we end up in this situation where when
you say the word like food deserts and
things like that where we feel like it's
a privilege that we as a as a privileged
society can go and help people that need
more our approach is the complete
opposite is we ask the communities what
they want and if it's okay if we come in
you know because once they give us the
okay that is that they want us then we
work from the ground up together
collaboration is important to Joy the
last couple of years he's traveled to
Copenhagen to speak to fellow chefs
about the stereotypes of street food and
the need to appeal to a younger and more
diverse generation even now in this
modern day what's being written about
Korean food or Chinese food or Taiwanese
food is being called ethnic because the
person who's writing it is is not from
those countries so then anything outside
of that is considered ethnic or foreign
to me it's not ethnic you know that's
who I am that's what I grew up with so
it's like I just think it's it's really
it's about changing the dialogue and
that's exactly what the food truck
revolution achieved it democratized the
dining experience by giving chefs a
low-cost business model to serve up
dishes to customers that pushed cultural
and culinary boundaries I'm really proud
of what we did it took the narrative out
of one voice and in it and it shared it
with many voices you know and then so we
got to tell our own stories and then
those became things that everyone was
attracted to for their own reasons yeah
I mean definitely more choices for
consumers out there for sure and again
it
you've got to experience something on
its own terms even though it's a very
small thing it allowed us to kind of see
what our possibilities are when we don't
like put race and culture and and and
labeling in front of us it's weird like
this country like we want our we still
think we have these Puritan ideals you
know like we think we're supposed to be
this one thing and we will never admit
that we're just like this crazy like
psychedelic like gumbo pot there is no
central point there is no like home base
like what we're just [ __ ] all over
the place
touched upon about the race thing but do
you see that getting worked out or is it
still something that is being avoided
you mean as a as a dialogue as a larger
as a larger country we're far ways away
but maybe through food the dialogue can
begin I'm doing this interview with you
now you know the reason no pun intended
I'm doing this is because you know I
felt like you guys want to have these
discussions you know it's gonna take
some time but again the way we look at
it is we're not expecting local to
change what's going on in this country
all the way like within the next month
what we're hoping to do is just start
the discussion and show some tangible
like change
Troy hooks that has experienced mixing
it up with street food will help local
uh sure and and
new kind of fast food revolution I
already lived through the food truck
revolution in my lifetime in the last
seven years I've seen before me people's
whole whole lives change whole
neighborhoods whole industries whole
stereotypes about how people used to
talk about by us brown people you know I
mean like about our food about what was
considered dirty and what was considered
clean you know horrible racist nicknames
and jokes and I've seen all of that
change into a huge industry that has
affected this whole world the way I see
this is if this is successful then what
happens is it's not just us then you
have real estate developers then you
have investors then you have politicians
all looking at these communities that
they've completely abandoned and coming
back and saying hey wait a second I can
invest in there I can build a mall right
here
can't build a movie theater right there
I can build a pizzeria in a baseball
field right there and we can't bring in
all these things in and start and then
we can bring in these jobs and then
corporations and and startups can say
okay I can I can invest in two
warehouses and distribution facilities
and offices over here and that can give
jobs out to the community and then all
of a sudden we create a whole other
economy within the economy